ceci est un clitoris je pense que pour
la plupart vous saviez pas maintenant
vous savez ça ressemble à ça aujourd'hui
je suis avec vous parce que je vais vous
expliquer un peu ce que c'est que cet
organe est chez vous expliquer surtout à
quoi ça sert et comment ça se fait
qu'aujourd'hui on fait tout ne s'est
dessiné un pénis et personnes s'est
dessinée qu'il faut savoir qu'en fait le
clitoris est le seul organe de tout le
corps humain qui est uniquement dédié au
plaisir
donc en fait cet organe est juste là
pour vous faire jouer et pour qu'on ait
du plaisir c'est pas mal le clitoris
possède lui 8000 terminaisons nerveuses
nerveuse là où le pénis en possède six
mille juste pour que vous ayez une
petite idée sur la pointe du doigt il ya
3000 terminaisons nerveuses un pénis
c'est un organe érectile qui se gorgent
de sang lors de l'excitation et qui
mesurent en moyenne entre 13 et 16
centièmes être et bien un clitoris
c'est un organe qui se gorgent de sang
lors de l'excitation et qui mesurent en
moyenne entre 11 et 13 cm donc en fait
c'est exactement la même chose et sa
cellule en
ça c'est le petit auris la cette partie
là vous la voyez pas ça c'est à
l'intérieur du vagin et ça c'est à
l'extérieur donc en fait le vagin il est
juste là et tout ça toute cette partie
interne du clitoris elle englobe le
vagin ya une espèce de croyance en fait
qui précise qu'il y aurait en fait deux
orgasmes un orgasme qui se veut
clitoridien et orgasme qui se veut
vaginale d'où la fameuse expression
était plutôt vaginale ou tu es plutôt
clitoridienne ça c'est en fait un mythe
dans le sens où tous les orgasmes son
clitoridien ce qu'il faut en fait dire
c'est un orgasme clitoridien par
stimulation externe
cette partie là où un orgasme
clitoridien partie simulation interne
qui en fait cette partie là mais ce
qu'il faut savoir c'est que dans tous
les cas si on a un orgasme
c'est grâce au clitoris pense que la
question qui revient le plus sur mon
compte c'est bonjour je j'ai un problème
je n'arrive pas à avoir d'orgasmes quand
je couche avec mon partenaire m'a écouté
pourquoi fins alors que la première
question que je pose c'est est ce que tu
te masturbes donc généralement on me
répond oui je leur dis comment tu te
masturbes par stimulation externe du
clitoris d'accord et je dis tu arrives à
avoir des orgasmes est comme ça oui
la master de ta part la pénétration nous
demandent à ce que ma soeur pour la
pénétration à non non ça c'est quelque
chose c'est que de moi moi et puis en
plus il va mal le prendre fin je
pourrais de le blesser et à cette peur
de vexer l'autre qui joue qui a un rôle
majeur sur la façon dont on aborde notre
sexualité le fait de se dire je n'ai pas
fait jouir concrètement que avec mon
pénis c'est pas ça être un mauvais coup
ça ça n'existe pas il ya même pas de
question d'ego il ya même pas de
questions de culpabilité à avoir là
dedans c'est pas ça c'est juste que
c'est purement physique et c'est pour ça
que c'est important de parler clitoris
parce qu'en fait quand on comprend
comment il est et comment et où est ce
qu'il est ou prend sens donc la notion
de l'obligation de la pénétration faut
arrêter avec ça et la communication
c'est super important
il ya rien de mal à masturber sa copine
ou sa femme ont peu importe sa
partenaire pendant la pénétration c'est
pas ça en fait pas un moins bon coup on
a moins bon amant ça ça n'existe pas
c'est pas vrai les hommes qui m'écrivent
ils me disent bonjour je ne sais pas
comment faire jouer à ma copine ça on me
le demande je pas peut-être 30 fois par
jour et je le redis demande lui avant de
faire un gâteau au chocolat on
t'explique comment le faire il ya des
personnes qui a su faire un gâteau au
chocolat sans qu'on lui apprenne passé
exactement la même chose y'a pas de mal
a demandé moi j'ai un clitoris depuis 23
ans
j'ai découvert il ya un an à quoi à quoi
ça ressemblait donc comment voulez vous
qu'un homme sache à quoi ça ressemble un
clitoris là ça va de soi nous les
sanglots longs pas ne les points t'ont
pas du doigt
expliquons lors tout simplement
moi je sais par exemple j'ai des règles
très douloureux châtain d'endométriose
le meilleur antalgiques de l'espace
c'est la masturbation antidépresseurs
anti stress quand j'ai quelque chose qui
va me stresser ou une grosse interview
où j'ai un gros entretien petite séance
de masturbation avant et en fait on
repart donc les bienfaits la
masturbation pareille c'est quelque
chose dont on ne parle pas alors qu' il
y en a et c'est quelque chose de bon et
c'est quelque chose de bon pour la santé
et c'est pas quelque chose de cynique et
chose de mal ni les joueuses de salles
ni quelque chose qu'on devrait réserver
pareil j'ai beaucoup de personnes qui
croient encore que à part ce moment on
est en couple on arrête de se masturber
beaucoup de femmes qui m'écrivent pour
ça en disant je suis en coupe du coup
j'ai arrêté de le masturber quel est le
lien
[Musique]
ceci étant pendentif c'est un clitoris
g7 ce pendentif parce qu'il ya un truc
qui me fait marrer c'est qu'on me
demande souvent s'il ya des gens qu'on
ne croit donc on leur dit dans ma fait
elle était chrétienne témoin je leur dis
bah non je clitoridienne cibler
s'emparer du symbole qui le clitoris ça
donne une perspective et ça donne en
fait un nouvel r c'est à dire qu'on n'a
plus envie de représenter féminisme et
les femmes par des utérus par des
ovaires qui à mon sens ramène encore une
fois la condition de la femme à sa
condition de génitrice or on est maire
si on a envie on est maire quand on en a
envie ça se trouve on sera jamais mer et
ça ne fait pas de nous des moins bonnes
ou des femmes moins respectable ou ou
quoi que ce soit donc le clitoris est
bien parce que ça permet de parler de
tout simplement prendre son pied